he's one of my favorite guys that I've
gotten to meet I'll say that and his
show is phenomenal its podcast is
phenomenal he's got a great sense about
what works in this day and age is
content and how to communicate it and
also he's on brand cuz he's a punter
from back in the day and he's two for
the price of one today Pat McAfee back
here on the Rich Eisen show from the Pat
McAfee show and Pat who do you have you
want to introduce our guest together on
your show once again the voice of the
NFL on a day-to-day basis on YouTube and
radio stations everywhere it's an honor
to chat with you sir I can't wait to see
what you do with the NFL Draft joining
you and I today for our standard
conversation is the other half of the
McAfee and Hawk sports talk show which
is currently live on YouTube right now
real longside currently live on youtube
alongside Rich Eisen show that is
currently live on YouTube mr. a Jayhawk
rich what's happening man I don't have a
huge long intro monologue for you but
it's good to do with you
so you're live on YouTube we're live on
YouTube and we're live on the radio I I
mean they can't they can't contain us
right now that's what you're saying Pat
right well I'm how this tech is working
to be honest because some days you can't
even connect a phone call that's live on
two different platforms and then also a
radio it's beautiful with how handsome a
Jayhawk is have you seen this guy's face
rich no not lately AJ do you want to
describe your face for me no I don't
rich but you know what yeah Rich Eisen
um 120 what do you think of we just we
call into Rich's show and we're on there
with him I said yeah why would you not
great Rich Eisen I grew up watching on
TV i watch everything you do that stage
a dude you're you're you're a good man
all right let's let's get into some
content let's get into some content
patent you and AJ could bat it around
I'll just hop in a little bit two days
where you know directing traffic a
little bit here and again we're on the
radio as well as well as well as
youtube.com slash Rich Eisen show what
do you think of Tom Brady Tampa Bay
Buccaneer Patrick what do you think of
that idea
you don't want rich I've been watching
you since I was like four or five years
old
i watch you cover the NFL I know that
there's always a couple different ways
to look at things in perspective and I
think the way to look at this particular
move is it's not the sexiest pick
I don't think Tampa Bay is the sexiest
but nobody thought Tampa Tommy was going
to be the move and and nobody thought a
city like champa Bay would be the one
that would land the greatest of all time
for his first time in free agency in 20
years but if you start looking at the
pieces of the puzzle down there the
picture starts coming a lot more clear
because Bruce Arians is there not only
handing over Rasta control and he's an
OG surrounded by a bunch of old coaches
who've been there done that with
everything but you got Godwin you got
Mike Evans everybody's saying Antonio
Braun is tied at the hip with Tom Brady
you bring him down to Tampa and that
taught boys defense that went from 32 to
5 last year all of a sudden you're
talking about a real contender now I
think the Patriots will be a good
football team because Belichick won't
allow them to completely suck but I
think they're much more in a rebuilding
phase than the Tampa Bay Buccaneers or
in a potential win it now phase and
that's why you bring in the handsome ass
Tom Brady how much belly do not feel but
that's how I feel about AJ but I was so
rich I have a question for you it seems
like it was between Tampa Bay yes and
the LA Chargers for Tom Brady that's
what it seemed like the two likely
candidates why do you think he chose
Tampa aside from the massive weapons he
has on all 15 potentially bringing in I
mean if I had to if I had a ballpark it
other than the geographic soundness of
being on the East Coast based on his
family situation I think the big answer
would be you know you look at Los
Angeles and if they are geographically
unsound that's number one but then
number two with all due respect and we
say that around here fully well aware
that what's about to come next is
somewhat disrespectful but we feel that
we have immunized ourselves to sounding
disrespectful Bruce Arians is the
difference I mean ba is one of the best
humans I've ever come across
Anthony Lynn is a great human as well
but Bruce Arians says has all that
experience in talking to quarterbacks
and has all that experience with Tom
Moore who
Brady knows from Peyton Manning is such
a a resource and then you plug Evans and
God went into it
the attack on no state tax and you got
yourself a winner I think I think your
honor ups inaccurate in that statement
the no state tax is gonna go a long way
to and every decision between Florida
and California but I think when Payton's
in Tom Brady you know their friendship
has really started to blossom on
Peyton's places they were golfing and
Jim Nancy's backyard I mean right I
think Peyton told Tom what life was like
for Peyton in the NFL you know like hey
if I wanted a guy cut I could get a guy
cut if I wanted to do this I could do
this and Tom Brady realized that 20
years into this thing he had literally
no control over a lot of things that a
lot of other great and iconic
quarterbacks have had control over and I
think Peyton probably said like hey PA
is a good guy to be around especially at
this stage he understands that you guys
are gonna work together clyde
christensen the quarterback coach is one
of Dayton's favorite humans I mean I
think Peyton Manning might have had a
little bit more say in this entire
decision than people could imagine but I
think whatever you start looking at it
if feels like it's the right decision
and I'm not a hundred percent sure the
media people love it because Tampa isn't
like you know I mean it's Tampa it's not
like Miami or or Boston or New York or
LA but I feel like they're gonna really
do some damage down there and I think
and when the stories come out I think
Peyton is potentially gonna be a part of
the conversation piece for Tom Bridge
well I got to jump in here Pat and pull
on that string a little bit you got a
good story of Peyton getting somebody
cut so I don't know if I ever saw him
actually cut somebody but there was a
couple times where in training camp a
player would sing when they were clearly
supposed to zag and there would be some
frustration from the sheriff and then
all of a sudden that guy just wasn't on
the team and I don't know if that was
Peyton or if I didn't know if that was
Bill Polian or the offensive people but
if Peyton wanted a guy on the field for
something that person was on the field
for something that's why you see him and
his wide receivers have such great
relationships because for Peyton he had
to work very very hard so those reps and
practice they had to go very very hard
and if Peyton wanted a curfew during the
Superbowl week there is a curfew during
Super Bowl II because if they'd wanted
the practice to go longer the practice
will no longer Peyton
to do something in the weight room that
would happen was that what it was like
in Green Bay with Aaron in them
AJ kids did Aaron have that type of
power well I don't think anyone really
had the power that Payton had like I
don't know maybe back in the day but no
in Green Bay I think it was Aaron has
plenty of power but I don't think he
ever chose to really use it like that if
he wanted like if he wasn't it like you
said if someone Zig and they should have
zagged he's gonna definitely coach his
guys up but it wasn't like he's gonna
get someone cut or he I don't know if he
had the power not if he really wanted to
and he wanted to go into GM's office and
tell him yeah maybe what happened but I
think Peyton what you witnessed with
Peyton man in Indianapolis was like an
unprecedented level of power that a
quarterback had that we're not really
gonna see moving forward and Pat you
been well Pat McAfee a Jayhawk here
together on the Rich Eisen show and
we're together on each other's YouTube
pages it's pretty crazy go ahead and
subscribe to their subscribe to mine as
well and we'll all be all better off for
it and and and you've got a front row
seat to Patrick on what Bruce Arians
could do with a quarterback right and
and his attitude is in and what he did
taking over for Chuck Pagano back in
what turned out to be a coach of the
year campaign for him in 2012 you got a
good story on that front very consistent
Bruce Arians is always going to be Bruce
Arians
he's very competitive and he it feels as
if he is also playing in the game with
you I don't know if that makes sense to
a lot of people but he's the first
offensive coordinator and last offense
coordinator where felt as if he was in
the game which before the game him going
to talk to guys It was as if a teammate
was talking like it was it felt like
Bruce Arians was just as competitive and
just as wanting to win as everybody else
and I told this story I think yesterday
or the day before either on my show or
back fee and hawk or the office Olympics
or at 3 o'clock every single day YouTube
comport I see faculty show I told this
story about how in the first Oh TA s
that Bruce Arians was there with the
offense he always had his signature look
you know they can go hat in the shorts
and he would wear shoes and you know
obviously the standard Bruce Arians look
that we've all come to down one ot a
practice he showed up in the next
morning where
all black yet a black Django had on a
black shirt black black everything and I
mentioned it you know I was like all new
look today Bruce and he goes yeah it's a
funeral we murdered them defensive boys
yesterday and then the whole defense was
there they heard him saying and they're
like oh no like he would chirp in
practice against the defensive players
like I just think that Bruce Arians and
Tom Brady we've seen Tom Brady oh you
know he's very he's very emotional he
will get loud he right he's like he is
the type of guy who's like that I think
he and Bruce will feed off each other in
a very good fashion and I'm kind of
excited to see those two kind of hook up
to be honest a Jayhawk Pat McAfee
together AJ what's going on with the
Houston Texans players right now in a
locker room based on what what happened
with DeAndre Hopkins being sent away
what do you think's happening in the
between the temples of anybody the place
for the Houston Texans right now well I
think they're all texting each other
right now seeing if any of them had you
ever have any interactions like this
like DeAndre like Michael Urban claims
DeAndre had but first off i gives andre
a lot of credit for coming out and kind
of downplaying it trying to make it less
of a story and say they kind of got
taken out of context not what it seemed
but i mean they're probably looking at
each other thinking what's our plan
moving forward we just tried to weigh
our best receivers one of the best
receivers in the NFL and we didn't get a
whole lot back yeah we got a good
running back coming over we know that he
can definitely revive this career here
and david johnson but I just I don't
know I think they're all a bit confused
I really do
Pat well I think they're looking at that
trades Detroit made today and they're
saying you know what at least we got a
second rounder for DeAndre instead of a
third rounder for the new highest-paid
corner in the league and you know I
think there's there's a couple of
there's been a couple decisions this you
know week a free agency that make you go
what the hell is going on
but if you're down there with Houston
you got to remember they had a hell of a
run this year they were up what 20 on
the Superbowl champion at one point in
the playoffs and then obviously they
give that up
deshaun Watson was making magic happen
that team it seemed like they were
potentially close to almost making it
like almost becoming a real squad and
now you trade away now there's always
going to be conversations of who the
best wide receiver in the game is
there's
a conversation in their situational
things that come up and you can't
outright say who's the best wide
receiver in the game
there's probably five people though that
are in that conversation four people
that are in that conversation for every
single year who the best wide receivers
in DeAndre Hopkins is in that
conversation for almost everybody the
guy makes insane catches it seems as if
the story that came out about his mom
and his teammates and now they're saying
there was a struggle of power and
welcome okay so his teammates like him a
lot if there's a struggle of power at
all I just it doesn't make a lot of
sense to us and I think Arizona got a
good one over there and I'd assume the
rest of the team is questioning what the
hell the motive is I got Pat McAfee and
a Jayhawk here together on their show
that's on their YouTube page we're on
our YouTube page I'm on my radio station
McAfee and Hawk a sports show
go and check their show out and
subscribe there and also subscribe here
at youtube.com slash Rich Eisen show
we're also on our radio affiliates we're
kind of Ghost Busters like crossing
streams together you're taking a look in
what they what they're doing we're
watching your guys's feed on your page
guys and and AJ did I notice are you
ripping a cigar right now with the times
we're living in now we're all stuck in
the house okay and everybody in the
house doesn't mind you smoking a cigar
in the house right now AJ well I have I
do have four young kids look em up like
in an attic that it's quarantined off
and the smoke does not travel throughout
the house I have multiple ways to get
the smoke out properly ventilated I hope
yeah yeah okay guys so we do this bit
here but the last couple of weeks rich
has one of the worst uber ratings we've
ever seen he's a 4 5 4 which is
virtually unheard of so just curious do
you guys know what your ratings are I
asked a Jayhawks to look up his too
because when Rich asked me to look this
up in funny way I think I was with rich
when he realized that his uber racing
I hit the over button and I'm like damn
it is still in the tank that's right it
was a it was a I mean it was a real
moment everybody started questioning
rich honestly have you ever heard of
someone with that level rating that's
unheard of you know I don't use the uber
that much okay so I wanted to backup
mine before judging rich I have a four
point eight one rating okay I'm all done
I was told that's not that good either
but I have this move where if I if I
request an XL SUV and you come with some
trash Toyota Highlander that is not an
issue I will cancel my trip oh yeah I
will cancel my trip I've been told that
that probably knocked me down so uh-huh
and well they're lying to me I don't
care I'm careful to brighten their faces
i lying to me this is not I also I think
what really brought my rating down was I
once drove an uber that I got because
the guy was driving too slow so I asked
him to get out of the car I Drive I
drove his car has to be break every
liability clause in any contract that
might be in the fine print pad so you
said get out I'm driving is that right
right well I had to figure out how to
address it I was sitting in the back
seat and I knew I was not gonna make my
flight pay for this guy continued to
drive in the fashion that he was driving
right I was and I was kind of locked
into the spot so I had to figure out how
you address getting the uber driver out
of his own car seat so I told him like
you know like is this the last one of
the day and he was like no it's my first
so I was gonna try to be like off it's
the last one like take it off so I had
to attack him in like four different
ways and basically the way I got him out
of there is I told him that I would pay
them 150 dollars cash if he just let me
drive his car he got out the shotgun and
said do your thing he tried to fall
asleep during the ride thankfully we
made it I made this bike and we
support by this room that gave me a good
3 3 star rating inactive mattifies what
about you AJ what's your what's your
rating
what's yours so my rating was four point
nine two is that good or not is it good
Oh Aaron Hawk that's legit right there
I've had the camper ride so I don't
cancel them like I don't all of a sudden
see the guy's face pop up and shows me
his card oh my god it's not good enough
for me I've never done that I thought
that like high-class like that is not I
I can't submit they you know if they're
five minutes away and I see another one
that's two minutes away I've done that
and that makes me worry about my rating
I want to stretch my knees out okay that
in your Highlander I know it you know if
you need what do you need a Sprinter van
III need Elisha silver water I need I
need a little bit of space I needed to
not only I need something to have
Suburbans good something that gives me
well there goes the toyota sponsorship
for AJ and for for Pat McAfee an a
Jayhawk a sports show but you've got at
least a lot more it's a deep end of the
pool for fight I cannot understand it I
got I've had people telling me that they
vomited in cars with better ratings now
I got a guy saying you're driving all
right let's do this more often this is
fun this is good you should we should
figure out the tech because we're trying
to stream your show on our stream but
it's a couple seconds behind all right
we'll figure it out all right Pat AJ
good chatting with you guys let's stay
in touch
appreciate it rich right back in well
fellas that is Pat McAfee and a Jayhawk
they have their own sports show on their
own YouTube feed that was fun there's a
lot of fun right there we have squeezed
every bit of juice out of this concept
that for some reason my uber ratings in
the toilette 492 club with a Jayhawk
I'll take that too Aaron Hawk and pour
for 204 rich what did you do honestly
nothing this guy I did not hook over the
dudes vehicle
I did nothing get out I did nothing I
swear I did nothing wrong
Grand Theft Auto I gave nothing and in
I'll keep repeating it I did zero I did
nothing I don't deserve it let's put it
that way I point the finger in other
directions